el expresidente Donald Trump dijo el
sábado que le iban a restar el martes
llamó a protestar y se fue a un evento
de lucha libre este domingo se conoció
un comunicado del fiscal que lleva el
caso en contra del expresidente un
mensaje dirigido a su equipo y revelado
por el medio de comunicación político
tenemos plena confianza en nuestro
destacado personal de seguridad e
investigadores junto con nuestros
excelentes colegas de la oficina
administrativa de la corte y la policía
de Nueva York y continuaremos
coordinándonos con todos ellos no
toleraremos los intentos de intimidar a
nuestra oficina o amenazar el estado de
derecho en Nueva York
Más allá de la expectativa mediática la
guerra política los republicanos se
sitúan al lado de quien Busca seguir
siendo su líder incluso su ex
vicepresidente Mike pence
esto se siente como un enjuiciamiento
con motivaciones políticas y yo por mi
parte siento que esto no es lo que el
pueblo estadounidense quiere ver tenemos
verdaderos desafíos en este país hoy
mientras que los demócratas ven una
oportunidad de inhabilitar a quien sería
el enemigo más temido para las
elecciones de 2024
Este es otro caso en el que Donald Trump
simplemente trata de promover los
intereses de Donald Trump no del resto
de la nación seamos claros sobre lo que
está pasando aquí nadie está por encima
de la ley ni siquiera el expresidente de
Estados Unidos
[Música]
un gran Jurado de Nueva York Investiga
los presuntos pagos de Trump durante la
campaña de 2016 para silenciar a la
actriz porno esto midainiels y a la
modelo de Playboy Karen McDonald por un
total de 280 mil dólares pagos
registrados como gastos legales y el
martes podría convertirse en el primer
expresidente en ser acusado de un delito